[Music]
so i have been wanting to do a video
using rice krispie treats in a new way
for so long because they're actually
malleable and you can make them into
different shapes
which means you can do just about
anything i also am pretty obsessed with
cheesecake as you guys may already know
so i decided to pair the two together so
because the flavor of rice krispie
treats is marshmallows i decided to lean
into the chocolate cheesecake because
it'll kind of bring together a s'mores
flavor which is a classic
i used a measuring cup but you can also
just go in there with your hands to
press it down into the springform pan
originally for some reason i thought you
could bake rice krispie treats and you
can't
i wanted to do a classic baked
cheesecake so the first time i made this
i made the rice krispies crust i poured
in the cheesecake batter i put it in the
oven and then disaster struck so i ended
up burning the original crust in the
oven so i realized that i had to go back
to the drawing board
but it actually was easy to fix because
i could just make a no-bake cheesecake
so cheesecake lovers may argue that the
only real kind of cheesecake is a baked
cheesecake but you can yield similar
results by making a no-bake cheesecake
and it is a little bit easier to do so
in a big cheesecake the eggs are going
to stabilize it whereas in a no-bake
cheesecake you have to use a different
stabilizing agent so a gelatin or in my
case i use the chocolate and whipped
cream so in order to make the crust out
of rice krispie treats you have to make
sure you're working quickly because
they're only malleable when they're
still warm
those are really the only key things to
remember for this recipe other than that
it's a pretty simple cheesecake just a
lot more fun
now once you make the cheesecake and you
cool it you can stop there but i decided
to decorate it because i really wanted
to go the extra mile so if you're eating
this by yourself feel free to stop here
but because i was bringing this to a
party i decided to go the extra mile and
decorate the top i know this recipe is
so sweet i'm not telling you to eat it
every day but you know for a treat
for a crispy treat
it was a winner
i'm not the best decorator but i really
tried to focus here and make sure i
nailed it because i only had one shot
now if you're concerned that your rice
crispy will get too hard while you're
cooling the cheesecake once the
cheesecake is set pull it out and leave
it on the counter for a few minutes and
your rice krispie treat should soften
right up and there you have it
snap crackle pop
is that like trademark
[Music]
so this video is actually my third video
i ever made for tasty i made this pie
for tasty for the holiday season and it
was such a smash hit that i to this day
still make it for my family during the
holidays too so one day i was thinking
about cinnamon rolls i was thinking
about apple pie and then
i just figure
why not have both
porque no dos
the visual you get once you bake this
pie is insane but let me tell you the
flavors are also really classic so i
decided to make a classic apple pie and
then utilize the cinnamon rolls for the
apple pie crust so i remember the
testing process of this pie was pretty
tricky but the end result is so
delicious i promise so the filling i use
for this is pretty classic and simple of
course we added some sugar and cinnamon
in there and the corn starch is there to
help thicken up the filling don't skip
it because then you'll have a watery pie
and no one
wants that
i prefer to use fresh apples in my apple
pies but feel free to switch up the
filling if you like you can cook down
your apples and use macerated apples
anything you want you do have to cut the
cinnamon rolls in half because you want
them to be small enough to form the
beautiful whirly crust my biggest piece
of advice for this is to use a serrated
knife because that will just make your
life so much easier so to simplify this
recipe we ended up using canned cinnamon
rolls because it just is so much easier
and a quicker process to get the crust
that you want when i was originally
testing this recipe i wasn't sure
whether i wanted to use pie dough or to
just use cinnamon rolls i decided to go
to the cinnamon rolls because it really
gave you that beautiful swirly visual
because if a cinnamon roll apple pie
doesn't have swirly cinnamon rolls then
is it really a cinnamon roll apple pie
probably not
[Music]
and one more big tip do not forget to
put the foil on top when you first bake
the pie this will ensure that the inside
of the pie bakes fully before the
outside crust ferns don't skip it don't
skip it don't skip it don't skip it
don't skip it
no you won't forget i hope
another reason i wanted to use the
canned cinnamon rolls is because they
all come with this delicious icing that
everybody knows from their childhood it
just takes it to the next level so the
reason i love making this pie for my own
thanksgiving is because it is such
a showstopper everyone is so impressed
when you put it down on the table it's
so beautiful
they wonder what's inside that feeling
never goes away and it's not only so
pretty it's also so delicious because
you get cinnamon rolls and an apple pie
in one kill two birds with one pot it
seems like a lot of my videos are taking
familiar flavors and then revamping them
with a new twist on a crust and i think
that's because the crust is a great
outward visual representation of the
recipe it's not always what's on the
inside that counts
i know
i
i know i'm not that shallow guys it is
what's on the inside that counts but
just for cinnamon roll apple pie it's
what is on the outside that counts i
hope you make this pie it was a
swirl
cinnamon
and spices
pie
i like pie
all right just make it
so i know this recipe is a little weird
but bear with me here the elements are
all pretty classic banana bread is one
of my all-time favorite foods not even
desserts like foods so it's one of my
favorite things to recreate for tasty
videos i'm not even quite sure how this
idea originally came to me i just
remember like looking at a banana and
being like oh my god kind of looks like
a corn dog
no like one
and then i had the next idea that you
could replace the cornbread crust with
banana bread and voila you got banana
bread on a stick now originally i was
like what do i call this banana dog
banana corn dog but i just settled on
banana bread on a stick because
i don't know banana corn dog kind of
sounds weird
so for this recipe i knew it was super
important to not only nail the flavor
but to make sure i nailed the shape and
look of a corn dog i wanted it to look
exactly the same but just a dessert
version so in order to get that straight
edge on the banana to look like a hot
dog i cut off the ends put a stick in
the middle and then save the ends to put
into the banana bread that i was gonna
make for the batter coating also it's a
great way to not waste any food although
you could have just eaten them
so there are a few tricky variables to
this recipe i have to make sure the
bananas would stay on the sticks
especially while dipping and frying
because bananas are a little more
fragile than like a hot dog would be so
i decided to freeze the bananas
beforehand now make sure you work
quickly because the bananas will thaw
and then you'll have
a mess
so i know frying bananas sounds a little
weird but you're really just frying
these to cook the banana bread all the
way through and then also get that nice
golden brown coating that every corndog
should have getting the temperature and
the timing right on frying was a little
bit tricky because in some batches i
didn't cook the banana bread quite all
the way through
and in other batches i cooked it far too
much and the banana ended up mushy in
the center so you're really going for
that perfect temperature and time to
cook the banana bread just through so i
know this recipe seems a little tricky
but i promise it's simple and trust me
it's a crowd pleaser so no corn dog is
complete without ketchup and mustard and
no banana dog is complete without
chocolate and caramel so i added both
options for dipping sauces i mean but
you could really dip it in anything you
want i don't know you could dip it in
ketchup or mustard
be kind of gross but
i'm still so proud of this video it was
a crazy idea
but it came out exactly how i pictured
it in my weird crazy mind riya even
tried these and she was a fan and you
know they don't call her the dessert's
not for nothing
seeing something that you've created
from start to finish being received well
by our audience is one of the most
gratifying feelings i know it's just
banana bread on a stick but it brought
happiness to people's lives and i'm
proud of it i felt like i was able to
bring happiness on a stick
[Music]
so i made this recipe video at a time
where cake rolls were
kind of trendy they were like the in
thing to do and i just wanted to play
around with the flavors and create
something that was delicious but also
new and interesting so the process looks
a little bit tricky when making a cake
roll because there are a few components
that you have to nail but it's actually
pretty simple when you break it down so
this cake batter calls for a lot of eggs
it's kind of like a sponge cake now you
want to make sure you're beating your
eggs before you go on to adding any
other ingredients because we're going to
incorporate some air into these eggs and
it'll make for a fluffier cake then all
the rest is pretty simple you'll just
dump in the rest of the ingredients and
switch to a folding method just to make
sure we're not over beating our cake
batter
[Music]
also just keep an eye when you're baking
this cake because it's so much thinner
it cooks really fast so be careful not
to burn your cake so now we get to some
of the more important steps once your
cake is baked you need to lay a clean
dish towel on your surface sprinkle that
with powdered sugar and then right when
you take it out of the oven you're going
to flip your cake over onto that towel
and quickly roll it up while the cake is
still hot because this will ensure once
you cool it in that form that it will
keep its roll shape without cracking a
very important step
so work quickly while it's still hot
don't burn yourselves you probably won't
it's fine but yeah the powdered sugar is
there to make sure your cake doesn't
stick to your towel so don't skip that
part either and don't use flour because
that's gross
so now your cake is cooling in its dish
towel i went on to make the filling
which is a simple kind of cheesecake
frosting it's one of my all-time
favorites so can't go wrong so when you
bring your cake back from the fridge
you're going to unroll it and it will
still have like kind of a it will still
kind of like i don't know go up
because it's like
molded to the roundness
oh man
so then you're just gonna lather all
that cheesecake frosting onto
the surface of the cake you're going to
sprinkle on some strawberries and then
it should be pretty easy from here on
out you just roll the cake back up into
its final form
this is like a shape shifter
shapeshifter cake i sprinkled my cake
with some more powdered sugar just to
make sure the outside looked nice and
you can also decorate it with some more
like strawberries or maybe some whipped
cream also another important step for
this cake if you're going to be serving
it to people or you want it to look
really beautiful is to chop off the ends
now i know it might seem wasteful but
you're really going to get the best
visual of that swirl when you chop off
the extra bits on end but you also get
that tasty visual
you can just eat them as a snack too
i did
i don't know why i always do this
all of a sudden it's like my signature
[Music]